hello and welcome to this video playing
hiya Jean from singapore right color
singapore yep singapore and okay let's
let's try ups let's try something else
mmm i remember haddam so what bad
experience against recently come in the
exchange way if i'm not mistaken so I'm
trying something else let's go for the
Scotch here the line that flooding my
chrome Drake has made popular h3 queen
of three something that I always
disliked and a little bit interface with
black always feel like White's game is a
bit easier so do I get this maybe is I
want to go Neji 3 and so on but see if I
know but I have c3m
oh it is your friend to take this would
be one looks very meek so let's not do
that maybe he's got see for an hour this
is the first time that I've seen this
position from White's point of view I've
had it on the board numerous times with
black so let's just move or wait just
too much Bishop g5 probably not them
doesn't do all that much we'll just go
to d7 and nothing happens okay so let's
retreat this hmm let's see that's an
interesting change of pawn structure
general I'm not so much against this
isn't this nice for white if equals
Bishop c5 I can take a four and 92 this
is a nice structure for white I get to
deform there's no tactic white no a five
should probably go a five
I hope it let's do this this is simple
and okay yes just double on the e from
should be good here yeah Jeff I was kind
of thinking can never take them but
maybe he can a for Bishop takes this may
be possible
it's not somewhat inconvenient no that's
not good I wanted an easy life here and
I think I actually made it difficult for
me
mmm what about if i go for for direct
attack there it's super difficult to
figure out anyway let's try look at this
and Roop g3 and so on now how
unnecessary I was such a actual easy to
play position probably I should have
gone a form okay here it's just that II
fiercest attack enough to not not take
them okay so night f51 just a Quincy one
okay it looks passive but let's let's
just keep this very good structure
intact it's not try anything too fancy
for
so how do I actually win this position
that's not so easy to say I mean not
that I'm winning but let me try to try
to get ahead somehow Queen to e5 he
probably wants to play let's just check
his ambition he's ok with the draw I
mean I'm not but said the repetition
actually I didn't want to repeat maybe I
just did how do i actually do something
it's not so easy Queen to e5 gym and
when I can that's not the end of the
world if it comes to e5 ok so this issue
with the a point is gone
not a problem anymore
13 yeah 3 here why is that Wow sorry
don't get it what is the trick this is
the trick time morning
might be able to d takes it's a bloody
cheek only one come on how stupid can
you be so I have to do this fast yeah
yeah so queena 492 and then take one you
for this is the right way to do it yeah
ok why do I open up the bloody long
diagonal this is really something that I
should answer losing control over this
unfortunately and play like it completed
yet again with the time ticking down
Chuck yes about this position I was
completely winning really very easily
quindi one now and now when i went to
pre movie i hear you get the point white
haha what an idiot this was a pretty
nice game I mean this is actually kind
of a model game how this slide is played
from here this is a super nice position
where you have good control he just has
this a pawn counter plane which is maybe
enough for him to make this still
playable but it's not my hat the way it
turned out it was
that was just waiting for white I really
play badly in those critical situation
at the moment even worse than I usually
do so King f1 winds immediately but this
is this all some wins I'm just not I'm
just playing like a [ __ ] so here what
what is tooth in quincy 559 f4i no one I
at you three I don't know i don't i
played badly like in those situations
especially at the moment I'm never
really good at this but I mean g3 is
just a terrible move why open up the
diagonal it's like I don't see a clear
idea and then I play whatever and d3 is
just bad and there is this check yeah I
just take stuff I mean cop yes to go on
we found this a night air force very
easy actually once you get there but I
get totally nervous at the moment I
don't know what it is really also here
Quincy five also is winning but i know i
know not not not good even here problem
there this this b5 still shouldn't lose
the position then I thought totally
totally losing any can sort of
coordination Queen d1 now it could have
done didn't do it that 25 and I was my
pre move Queenie a draw yeah I don't
know currently I'm don't have a good
nervous system and when the time is
ticking down I like the game before that
I think it was quite okay but um yeah
gifting gifting this away is not good
okay thanks
watching